speaking of prognosticators it was a bad
week I saw this this is the headline in
the headline the cover of Newsweek it's
Trump on the cover You Ain't Seen
Nothing Yet now of course he could still
make a big comeback but I feel like this
isn't another thing that was done when
we all thought it was going to be a big
red wave and it looks really bad now and
this happens this happens all the time
it happens in publishing we've noticed
here on this this show uh we do a
segment called books that didn't age
well
[Applause]
we used demographic for what we lost it
but anyway uh does
but Liz truss is the prime minister was
the Prime Minister for 45 days
in England and there was when she as
soon as she was elected they put out a
book called out of the blue Liz trust
there it is and how she's going to do
great well I mean this is an example of
what we're talking about books that did
not age well would you like to see some
of the others
yeah there's a lot of them
it's like uh
Herschel Walkers What to Expect When
You're Expecting did not as well
good night
uh Paul Pelosi's home security for
dummies did not age
Adam Levine's big book of baby names was
just not
a great idea Kanye West's uncancelable
how to insulate yourself from media
Fallout
um Elon musk's stealth the art of taking
over a company without Making Waves was
not
um oh Thomas Friedman's reissue of the
World is Flat with a new introduction by
Kyrie Irving was just
Queen Elizabeth kiss my ass Betty White
living to 101.
and to Tom and Gisele Brady meshing
marriage and career our guide to having
it all